Speaker 1: In other news, Mary Trump, niece
of former President Donald Trump, came out
with a phenomenal article in The New Republic
recently where she basically, well, she psychoanalyzed
a lot of her uncle's administration.
But there's one part that I want to hit on
more than others, and that is the part where
she talks about the big lie, right?
The big lie that the election was stolen,
which, as she points out, Donald Trump began
telling that lie on November 7th, which was
the day that the 2020 election was officially
called for Joe Biden.
And on that very day, he started the Big Lie
and of course, he had all the horrible people
whispering in his ear that, oh, here you got
to do this.
Giuliani was there.
Mark Meadows was there.
All these individuals, even some private lawyers
telling him, you've got to challenge this,
you got to say it was fake.
And Mary Trump says that the reason her uncle
did this.
Is because he was absolutely humiliated, humiliated
by the fact that he lost the presidential
election to Joe Biden.
All this was.
Was his hubris not allowing him to accept
the fact that he lost to somebody like Joe
Biden?
And so he had to, as a defense mechanism for
himself, create this alternative timeline,
this alternative reality.
We're in his head.
He actually won the election because of all
the fraud.
So we had the election challenges, we've had
the recounts, we've had to go through and
recertify, we've had the signature match,
we now have the ballot audits.
And all of it, she points out, is this defense
mechanism to protect his bruised ego.
The humiliation that he still feels to this
day.
For losing that election.
But the problem is his delusion, his defense
mechanism is not just limited to him now.
It is in psychological terms, a shared psychosis
now.
Right, it has seemingly infected millions
of others who have now been sucked into the
delusion to believe that the 2020 election
was stolen.
I mean, how many polls have we seen just over
the last two months showing a majority of
Republicans now think the election was stolen?
That's a terrifying thought.
I haven't seen any polls in the last couple
of weeks, so maybe that number has changed,
maybe it's going back down and you don't have
a majority of Republicans thinking that anymore.
But the fact that we ever did that, we ever
even hit 60 percent of Republicans saying
this is terrifying because there was never
any fraud.
In fact, the few cases of fraud that we found,
the individual cases all appear to be Trump
supporters.
That's what we're living with, but they still
can't accept it because he won't accept it
and he'll never accept it.
To the day he dies, Donald Trump, every time
he gets in front of a camera or he gets a
microphone, is going to remind us that he
thinks the 2020 election was stolen.
He has done that this year.
Every time he gets on stage, every time he
has an audience, he says the same thing.
Even though the ballot audits have produced
no fraud, even though the recounts have produced
no fraud, even though the lawsuits have produced
no fraud, even though the cyber symposium
produced no hacking evidence at all, no fraud.
He'll never stop.
And Mary, Trump's explanation of this really
lays it all bare.
He won't stop because he can't stop because
his narcissism simply won't let him.
I am Ferren Cousins in for David Pakman, we'll
be right back with more of The David Pakman
Show